updating your iPhone software lets Apple
nuke your phone to make you buy a new
phone is what a shocking number of you
seem to actually believe just based on
the reactions to the time I tweeted
about it so let me just break down
what's actually happening and then we
can be the judge of it the laws of
chemistry say that batteries naturally
degrade over time so the maximum power
that they can output slowly goes down
over time so Apple chose to do is
underclock the CPU of iPhones with older
degraded batteries to prevent them from
hitting the lower battery power limit
the problem is they did this for a while
without telling anyone so that's where
the conspiracy sort of started years ago
they eventually got called out publicly
and had to admit it and paid 100 plus
million dollar lawsuit out over it but
now if your old iPhone experiences an
unexpected shutdown due to the battery
and not being able to supply enough
power a new setting appears that
literally gives you the option to keep
running at full speeds anyway but at the
end of the day this behavior is built
into the iPhone you already have not in
the software update waiting for you so
go ahead and update your phone for
Security's sake also if you have an Old
Slow phone consider replacing the
battery instead of the whole phone it
literally gets faster again you're
welcome